when i say good you say news good no
good no
people reports jennifer lopez is
sporting a green engagement ring from
ben affleck her sister linda shared a
pic on instagram with a huge
congratulations that went super viral
asap
and jennifer says green is a lucky color
for her um i mean it certainly is she
wore that versace dress we all remember
that oh i remember that she has a big
piece of barbara krueger art that has
like green hummingbirds she's actually
like the green is a good color for an
important meaningful significant one
yeah well this is significant and i'm
obsessed with this i've always been
fascinated by people who like break up
and then years later get back together
am i the only one that's fascinated by
that you guys know because raise your
hand if you're into
second chances yes heat up those
leftovers honey get on they're still
good
it turns out the boston business journal
reports
smile
is a dating app that matches people by
sense of humor really yes
[Music]
it's developed by melissa mullen and it
launches april 15th now here's how it
works instead of swipe on profile pics
your zoo's
users will rate funny content from tick
tock and instagram and then an algorithm
will match your sense of humor to people
who laugh at the same things that you
find funny it's like funny bone to funny
bone yes um and the um
and the
app also plans to blur
um profile pics at first so that you
don't get a full view of someone until
you've been chatting for a bit like it's
humor overlooks
i mean
what do you think
i i'm really into this jaw lines will
sag right but
lols are here forever this story comes
from the week chloe campbell started
working at the coffee pot her local
coffee shop in dubtown scotland when she
was just 15. and now four years later
she bought the place hey chloe that's
right
chloe says her parents taught her to
save money so she saved and saved and
saved every check she made she saved and
then she mentioned to the owner that she
was thinking about running her own place
one day and then the owner said buy this
one and she did wow
congratulations chloe she's 19
and owns her own business
that's amazing
amazing
15 she started working when i was 15 i
worked at mcdonald's and and then i
worked there for four years and you were
the triple threat i was a triple threat
register drive-through and grill and all
all i ever got was was transferred to
the mcdonald's express in the mall which
was like
you know what i mean how did that how
did that feel it wasn't great it wasn't
great and it's all cause steve the
manager and steve take the kick you know
who you are steve
you know where you are and you didn't
like me well
what's up steve
so food and wine reports that venice has
an aggressive seagull problem and
restaurants are providing guests with
table side water guns to squirt out
if they get too close to your old
spaghetti olive oil
they tried using an irritating sound
that humans couldn't hear but they could
didn't work they tried unleashing
falcons a bigger scarier bird didn't
work
they'd say so they settled on super
soakers this is kind of what i like
about the seagulls though
is like they're scrappy and tenacious
you can't just easily get rid of them i
like that the question is right if say i
had a plate of fries right here and drew
was being like a seagull looking at my
fries if i had a squirt gun
[Applause]
just try it barrymore
okay well first of all okay oh no
try it
[Applause]
down down
it worked it worked it worked
it worked
[Laughter]
i got a whole mouthful
[Music]
you